hier haben wir jetzt ein croissant ich
habe gerade erst mal meine finger wir
waren schon voll mit schokolade
überzogen mit georgia und nutella also
wir haben wir auf jeden fall kinder
schokolade oben drüber
eins zwei drei oder vier majors gedacht
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video
er wollte ich hoffe natürlich geht es
gut mir auch also gleich gehts mit euch
noch besser ich muss sagen ich habe das
video praktisch schon heute nachmittag
angefangen gerade wird schon ein
bisschen dunkel draußen haben schon 18
wurf auf jeden fall eine zuschauerin
geschrieben alex in köln gibt so einen
donut lagen machen so richtig krank
ausgefallene donuts und ich habe da
danach richtig geschrieben ob wir nicht
mal rock hätten wir so ein paar donuts
fertig zu machen für ein video also das
sind halt wirklich nicht so das thema
jetzt kenne wie dunkin' donuts
standarddünger sondern wirklich so
richtig dicke dona kreationen und da bin
ich eben hin gefahren ich würde sagen
das zeige ich euch erstmal weil wir
haben auch so praktisch eins und donald
zusammen gemacht oder er hat vorgemacht
wie das geht irgendwie dann auch so mit
klappe und so dass das alles verschmilzt
und wir haben jetzt insgesamt acht
donuts die wir testen können wirklich
ganz heftige dinger also einer ist sogar
ein croissant eigentlich das habe ich
jetzt auch noch nicht ganz verstanden
ich würde sagen ich hol dir mal kurz die
sind im kühlschrank und dann sehen wir
uns sofort wieder ab jetzt erstmal die
ausschnitte von einer damit letztlich im
dunkeln irgendwie das wetter leute wir
machen uns auf den weg und will ihr ein
bisschen heller zur dominanten faktoren
ich jetzt mal so da wo die ganzen monats
eingestellt werden ich weitermachen
und ich bin mal gespannt was mich
erwartet jetzt erstmal los und so das
ganze ist übrigens auch kein test oder
sonst was ich ab modernster seite
gesehen die komme aus köln haben einfach
mal geschrieben und dann meinten die so
jung wir machen die richtig heiße dort
aus war es auch klassiker wie oh immer
gerne
deswegen kommt jetzt plane da also wie
lange habe ich eigentlich nicht mehr im
auto gefilmt früher habe ich das höre
gemacht
15 uhr habe ich den termin dort wir
haben jetzt 14 uhr 48 12 minuten
da schaue ich ob ich bin jetzt hier bei
royal donuts in köln
die adressen ändern sagt war die straße
luxemburg straße 82 also ja okay und ich
will jetzt einmal gezeigt wie sollen wir
so einen donut gemacht wird ich habe ja
schon gesehen habe ich schon so ein paar
kreationen zubereitet und dann zeige ich
euch die gleich mal aber jetzt erstmal
hier paar techniken oder so paar
geheimnisse was auch immer
das kann zb sich immer auch als ausnahme
zu machen also jeder du bist immer
aufgeschnitten wird nicht jeder darf
wir haben einige die aufgeschnitten
werden aufgrund dessen dass wir manchmal
topping farben die er eingelegt werden
und gstrein gespritzt werden
[Musik]
frische selbst gemacht
warstein
[Musik]
dort kehren ok fertig wäre 91 mal
perfekt
der sieht auch klaus wallbaum kreation
wird die kanzlerin bonk reaktion
customized beobachten wir dass da kann
der kunde selbst entscheiden was als
füllung reinkommt welche creme welche
klausur werde toppings wie viele
toppings welche saucen und quasi
komplett der fantasie freien lauf
das drücke das auch das was uns ausmacht
wird also keine vorgefertigten zu
sondern mit ungeplant war sich exakt
selbst bestimmen kreiert haben wir genau
hier oben haben wir einmal den der extra
für mich noch gemacht wurde sieht
schonmal ganz geld aus oder schön wie im
schaufenster und hier drin haben wir
halt die anderen
ich habe überlegt wie man einfach wieder
verbreitung vom feld fertig sagen alles
fertig ist gut geworden ich freue mich
jetzt schon so die zu testen also es
riecht auf jeden fall brutal wie viele
haben wir denn jetzt hier eigentlich 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 stück alter ich weiß gar
nicht womit ich anfangen soll ich will
erst mal kurz zum teil auch okay dass
ich voll schwierig niemand den hier als
erstes okay ach so was mal ganz kurz
nach deren installierte checken weil
darüber weil ich dachte wow das sieht
echt nice aus das zeige ich euch mal
kurz bin ich überhaupt so auch die
aufmerksam geworden also leute die haben
wir die instagram seite und das sind
halt so kreation da dachte ich schon als
sie krank aus
das natürlich auch irgendwie alles also
es sind halt sachen die kennt man so
nicht und deswegen habe ich auch gedacht
da lohnt es sich mal richtig dicken
video für zu drehen
checkt auch super gerne mal die seite ab
schöne grüße hier die verschicken auch
alle donuts und so man kann der online
bestellen man kann sich selber
zusammenstellen könnte ja dann mal
rausfinden probiere ich einfach einen
nach dem anderen und vergebenen noten
welche am besten ist jetzt das erst mal
gucken was da drauf ist also ich kann ja
nicht sagen schokolade weiße schokolade
und hier drin ist auch irgendwas mit
schokolade und hier ist auch schokolade
also schokolade
[Applaus]
wenn das jetzt mit allen neuen züge
komplett mich als und lecker aber ist
noch keine zehn war es echt richtig
lecker schmeckt nach donath mit
schokolade also schwierig zu sagen
brocken und hier sind top drauf kann ich
jetzt nicht sagen
schwenkt ultra geil ich weiß es nicht
genau was da für zutaten drin sind sieht
ein bisschen aus wie kinder pinguin oder
oder milch schnitte oder soja irgendwie
so keine ahnung
naja nehmen wir mal den nächsten zehn
meter brett studiert er ist ein bisschen
kleiner ist auch interessant das ist
jetzt hier der brezel donath anscheinend
klebe ich auf jeden fall ziemlich gar
nicht doch das soll auch nicht ist der
erdnuss butter drauf oder so ja sieht
das vielleicht so ich weiß es nicht
der hier war besser in fahrt ist nicht
ganz so aber wir haben ja auch noch
achtmal als nächstes du hast ja
aussuchen wenn solche den grünen den
also wir haben hier auf jeden fall
kinder schokolade oben drüber dann so
grüne glasur also zuckerglasur ein
bisschen schokolade noch drin
ihr habt ja eben gesehen wie die gemacht
werden also die werden ja aufgeschnitten
dann kommt er sondern seine schokosoße
rein und ich glaube das haben wir
gemacht also probiere ich mal auch
richtig lecker aber immer noch nicht so
gut wie der erste den wir als erstes
haben und ich konnte jetzt die opfer
eben nur ein bisschen wir uns mehr
danach erstellt was soll ich jetzt dazu
sagen mir fällt nichts ein schmeckt gut
mehr kann man nicht sagen
dann lass uns das doch punkte vergeben
die heiße regal heute vergeblich keine
punkte
alle so alle sist souverän kann man
essen nicht so viel weil das ja auch
nicht gut vom körper aber lassen wir
jetzt
jetzt kommt das krasse ist das wollte
ich eigentlich auch um schlussmann aber
ich mache es jetzt einfach und zwar
haben wir hier das mal auf ein croissant
hier jetzt ein croissant
ich habe gerade erst mal meine finger
gewaschen die waren schon voll mit
schokolade überzogen mit toto und
nutella höchst interessante kreationen
absolut keinen plan ob das schmecken
kann sieht auf jeden fall trage und hier
sind ja auch so pistazien dinge drauf
hast du chocolat komplett weiß
ich habe noch so gute saison gesetzt und
wollte mal probieren ja auch mal
probieren dann war ich in der zeit mein
mund ist im glück hinzu insgesamt leute
so sieht das übrigens von innen aus ich
glaube da ist ja scharf stellen mittel
und ich glaube da ist so ein bisschen
pistazie oder so drin auch oder oder
schokolade nutella ok ja auch neid und
hass den herren geschmeckt total echt
richtig geil also ich glaube das ist das
lecker zu sagen was ich hier gegessen
habe so dass ich morgens zum frühstück
dann sehe ich aber irgendwann nicht mehr
so aus wie jetzt aus naja solange weiter
ich habe eigentlich gedacht wir machen
hier mal eben den blaubär donath also
das ist eigentlich würde ich mal sagen
der langweiligste verneigen sage ich mal
so aber kann man natürlich trotzdem
testen 321 liter auf jeden fall feiere
ich allerdings nicht so wie den ersten
der erste lauf ist jetzt auf jeden fall
der beste deswegen auch du hier ganz
schnell wieder rein oder möchte denn
jemand danach wurde
danach können wir alle auf also jetzt
haben wir noch warte mal ich hole jetzt
einfach mal ab den rest raus den wir
brauchen
der weiße auch noch ich bin sehr
gespannt wie oft unter diesem video
steht jetzt habe ich hunger und jetzt
haben wir eigentlich noch den krassesten
der ja eben gemacht wurde ich glaube
dann habt ihr schon mal gesehen wir
haben einen donut kreation brownies
obendrauf marshmallows das ganze
blamiert was das hier oben weiß ich
nicht mehr ganz genau und ziemlich viel
schokolade dazwischen das sind auf jeden
fall jetzt hier die rasten ihr könnt
jetzt ja mal in die kommentare schreiben
welche davon am liebsten genau jetzt
dessen würdet 1 2 3 oder 4
also ich bin mit dem hobby wie es
eigentlich am besten kalorien sind das
wohl 3000 mehr oder
wir sollten jetzt weitermachen ich will
eigentlich erstmal den keks essen haben
die auch nachts mit huub smit aus
das weiß ich gar nicht glauben ich das
ist auf jeden fall der beste xaver war
da und jetzt kurz den ton an
oder so er ist auch ich gehe dann kam
also nichts zu bemängeln
würdest du gerne 11 von 14 war das schon
ich wollte dass sie eigentlich man erst
mal toppen wärst du weitermachen und so
ich glaube ich kann echt weiter ist das
ist mir leider schlecht muss nur noch
zweimal weiß ja ich kein echtes stelle
kurz becher jetzt sehr viel doch so
schön passt du dein polit das ist ihr
schmecken
ich mag gerne die kekse die also das
kannst du ja auch noch ein bisschen was
ist eigentlich nur noch der jeweils
nicht zu heiß und ich kann es auch
probieren
aber den habe ich noch nicht an dem
problem wenn man einwohner davon
eigentlich schon echt krass aus mit
denen experten sagen sie ich habe mir
noch mal rein und bewertungen von 1 bis
das soll der erste richtig die sonne von
mir schon noch gerne acht geben oder 918
910 hat nicht ganz gereicht da werden
wir richtig zu viel schokolade familie
also alles ich bin doch warum macht es
viel besser als du da problemlos nicht
gehen dass der dickste auf jeden fall
man muss ja direkt die hände waschen
krasse inzwischen mutter sale oder nee
das kann und will ich weiß gar nicht ich
glaube nicht ordne ist an der aktion
nicht mehr nur mit fakten
mein ziel wäre dass alle auf kriegen
von den vier noch kleinsten also ich
kann nicht weiter essen so schlecht dass
man also schmeckt mega gut auf jeden
fall keine frage hier damit es an bord
genau da ist alles drin ich bin
eigentlich schon sagen wir haben alle
wird es war echt leistung folge für
hilfs stellt euch die selber gerne macht
und das war bis jetzt also die
heftigsten als wäre ich je gegessen habe
und das heftigste croissant so das war's
mit dem video wir sehen uns morgen um 19
uhr instagram alex w und danke für dein
gast